also ich sage ihnen ganz klar wenn es
jetzt so wäre dass wir in acht wochen
nehmen wir mal an zusätzlicher weitere
zwei monate also februar und märz hätten
dann bin ich mir sicher dann brauchen
wir noch mal mindestens 20 milliarden
zusätzlich alleine für die wirtschaft
dann haben wir noch zusätzliche kosten
wechselwirkungen für gesundheit das
dürfte noch mal fünf bis zehn milliarden
werden
und ich weiß noch nicht was das für die
bundesagentur für arbeit bedeuten würde
die dann aber wahrscheinlich einen
weiteren zusätzlichen darf und nochmals
zehn milliarden haben und dann kommen
sie auf ungefähr 40 milliarden
zigmal jahren 40 milliarden zusätzlicher
nachtragshaushalt das ist das was sie
sagen maximal könnte da kommen wenn wir
noch acht wochen im lock down sind
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren